andrew schultz is with us what's up
everybody uh you had a special that you
sold to 4chan
they then
they then said it i almost cut you off
and i was like do we have to talk about
right away and i was like no i think
there's something here yeah because
4chan said this is too much they did
they said for our platform yeah
it's too much and now you have to no i
don't want to talk about it right away
but i do want to say
good for you for buying it back thank
you and doing it independently thank you
see i cried out i cucked out i gave
money to netflix for 35
listen
listen
you're gonna get your money's worth i i
owe too much in mortgages to play games
that's what i was saying before this is
like you're so smart with [ __ ] real
estate you like understand this game i
don't know you're gonna be humble but
you do understand it a little i
understand it more than i used to
because i've foreclosed on probably i
[ __ ] so much up that i'm a little
better now i'm better that's the
confidence that's right i think it's
like i'm i have this fear that if
something goes wrong like i'm like they
just take everything like i don't
understand what foreclosure is right but
you've went through the darkest part and
you're like oh you just get to be a
celebrity after actually fun yeah it's
actually fun it doesn't really matter
nothing matters especially you might as
well buy it all new york is like a
non-recourse state so they can't even go
after the money you have in your bank
account they can just go after the house
so they can just take the house you know
you just you know yeah you put
everything in somebody's name for a
couple of years you declare bankruptcy
you wipe it out it's fun it's not a big
deal going broke is actually kind of fun
it's liberating it's liberating yeah
what a white perspective yeah yeah going
broke is a
liberating and spiritual experience it's
my new seminar that i'm running um but
you take chances all over the place if
it's on me i feel more comfortable
taking the chance you'll do it because i
can control it a little bit more yes you
know what i mean absolutely like i can i
can work on the stand-up i can work on
the podcast i can make them
funny i can make them interesting i can
i can actually change that i i can't do
anything to [ __ ] t i can't do
anything to a bitcoin i can't do
anything to these other assets i admire
people who just like do the research and
know what's going to happen and you were
saying the interest rate's going to go
like this i don't know anything about
that but i i can make more content the
game is that i don't either but it's but
it's pretend see pretend when you were a
kid remember you would play pretend with
people and you would make up that you
know you guys were doing something you
know whoever is the power rangers
whatever you are yeah uh that's all this
economy is uh we actually never grow out
of that we never grow out of like
playing pretend yeah people just get
better at it and then they get to live
in palm beach
or manhattan yes or wherever and people
are just really good at playing so i'm
trying to play real yes when i should be
trying to play pretend yes you just just
hold forth on something like just
for breakfast you sit in there yeah and
you're doing a shakshuka or whatever and
you pierce the egg with the knife and
you eat it and then you go the interest
rates and don't even have anything
planned after that even after that third
word after rates don't even have
anything planned just go the interest
rate and you'll find it you'll find it
and they don't know either yes because
they're listening to you from them they
have no idea if you're loud if you're
loud and kind of passionate you should
do a podcast like that yes i know that
would be like a brilliant business plan
yeah that would probably be incredibly
successful and people around the world
would listen to it it would be amazing
yeah it would be amazing like i would
love that if there was a guy yeah who
did a podcast where he pretended to know
about a lot of things yeah like a little
bit about a lot of things yeah yeah and
he was healthy
and smoked weed does he need to be
healthy uh yeah because it helps okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well i think
that's a great blog you think i'm
talking about joe
i'm talking about you you're not talking
about a job
but that's that's the brilliance of his
show
is that he does know a lot yeah
but what he doesn't know he just kind of
rolls with it ah you know and that's why
you that's what you got to do
this special did you know they were
going to
[ __ ] you a little
no
yeah but
originally listen i i thought it was
there was going to be maybe issues yeah
but i showed him everything so it was
like you know what you're getting in bed
with right
and then
i think it was the trans [ __ ] with
chappelle that that scared the [ __ ] out
of them terrified people yeah and they
said this is too much
yeah they're like we just want you to
cut these different things and i was
just like i'm not gonna do it no and i
also like
i'd never done
stand up for a network right so i never
went through the notes process right i'd
always just done youtube and instagram
and [ __ ] so like yeah
i i felt weird and i was like i'm not
about to water it down now that i have
this big beautiful thing no you've built
this thing on your own exactly and now
yeah you're you're past the notes face
exactly for sure and i felt that way and
obviously they're thinking okay he's not
big enough to take the risk which is
fine you have to make that assessment
that's cool i'm not even offended by
that like right you don't love stand-up
like i love stand-up you love building a
business that's cool that's great i love
this [ __ ] if it was a [ __ ] movie or
something and you wrote it all and you
want to edit my line i didn't i don't
give a [ __ ] i don't care about acting i
hate it yeah i'll be honest with you
it's more personal to us to them it's a
transaction exactly so i understand why
they feel this way about it and why they
want to protect the brand sure and i'm
sure they on some level understand why i
feel so strongly about it because this
is my whole [ __ ] identity my whole
career this is the that you put years
into this yeah people know me from stand
up right they they found my podcast
after right for sure so it's like
yeah it was very hard for me to to just
be like willy-nilly let the control
go away exactly and i'm not gonna ask
what streamer it is um i just know that
it's not netflix because netflix is so
desperate right now they would take
anything they asked me to re-cut my
special where i say the n-word really
and because they just want attention you
cut the joke about the n-word they said
no they said can you just start
screaming the n-word what was that thing
you were working out when the guy was
giving you the parking ticket
like i saw you you were working out that
joke and then you were like just you
said it was a joke and you were just
screaming the n-word at him but you were
like it's a bit no the man i think oh
yeah yeah he's putting the ticket on it
it was a bit where i said how dare you
and word give me a ticket yeah yeah yeah
yeah what that is is i like to workshop
bits in life
because i find that the stage a lot of
times is incredibly it's not honestly
limited times yeah no yeah it it's uh
it's good to
have a
i think
confidence in your fan base
and in yourself
that you've kind of always done you've
always done your own thing you don't
care yeah i mean that's the gamble right
that's the gamble the gamble is too we
know so many people that are unhappy
because for whatever reason you know
they feel like they're at a job
yeah and like you also make that choice
like security is nice like people will
sacrifice freedom for security like
every single [ __ ] day so i get why
they make that decision but uh
and they don't want to do this because i
think a lot of people just don't want to
know how much they're worth i think
that's the scariest thing about this to
most people and that's why people don't
leave institutions like snl is a cozy
[ __ ] job sure right but like you
don't really know if people [ __ ] with
you or if they [ __ ] with the team the
brand exactly so like i love everybody
on the knicks and then if they get
traded
[ __ ] them
right and you don't know if people love
you
or if you're tradable yeah
finding out your own value and knowing
and i think mike lawrence
uh comedian said about los angeles that
like
it was a terrifying city for a lot of
people in new york because they appraise
your worth immediately uh yeah yeah like
because it's all like dollars and cents
yeah it's not so much like oh you're
talented or you people come here to make
to be successful because yeah that's
what people value out here is that's
right like what is hot that's right and
in new york people what's good it's yo
we we like
it this sounds super [ __ ] corny we we
kind of like art yeah and it's like you
like the kid who dresses cool or the the
music that is interesting and that has
value right and like even the
weird-looking fashion model is cooler in
new york for whatever reason than here
exactly right here it's just hot hot hot
so when you got hot here yeah [ __ ]
changed for you when i was here before
that i it was very dark and but it was
fun
but it was like invisible but when you
saw the flip
yeah
for me
i would resent [ __ ]
like for me it'd be hard because
now i know we don't have the same values
sure so it'd be like okay
you like this because right you know
when
yeah that i would i would i would be
resentful yeah i i'm
i think that's a that's an interesting
thing
i think what
what
what it is more is accepting of the game
because it's i i don't even blame those
people
they're just existing in this
singular focus how do i make it it's
just they're existing in this world
that's all been decided for them yeah
and they kind of when i had nothing
going on they were like dismissive and
then i had more going on and they were
like hey what's up
i think that's just the way the town
operates that's the town and you can't
at a certain point you notice you can't
fight city hall but
i i yeah listen it's never been it
doesn't you know and you can choose who
you help
yeah that's true that's and that's where
them it plays it's like oh and that
person didn't respond to your messages
when you just were saying hey i really
thought your set was good right and now
they're all up your ass yeah it's like
okay
i don't have to necessarily put my
resources into helping build you because
you might not have the same like code
yeah as i have yeah i mean that's
that's probably a lot of what i think
people
are scared of when they treat people
like [ __ ] it's that one day it turns on
them yeah right so there's a lot of
people that treat people poorly which is
never the right thing to do right but a
lot of times it does turn yeah you know
and there's many instances of that in
this business where like somebody
does shoot up for whatever reason but
people were pretty nice to me i don't
think anyone was ever a dick i think
people were just kind of like they were
in their own lane doing their own thing
i also think i'm not as emotional as
other people get very emotional
well people get very emotional about
how they're
um treated
uh like people get very
like
you know they're easily offended or
their feelings get hurt well yeah
because they're probably insecure about
something yeah you feel that way already
about themselves right then it gets
validated right i always was like yeah
that person's busy
that person is doing something
why should they know me
like it was always back on me and maybe
that's a
cause you cold-called
it's
people
you went through immense rejection yeah
and you start to realize oh yeah that
person is picking up their kids from
school that's not why they're home at
third time it's it's because to me i was
always like if you internalize every
brush it's brutal it's brutal it's
brutal but at the same time we're human
bro we're we are human you know we're
going to internalize some things yeah
for sure it's hard to not personalize it
it's also like but i would sometimes and
then i'd catch myself i'd be like just
what who cares yeah and then you try to
move on well profits let people convert
tim
yeah that's true that's very good that's
a who said that muhammad probably
muhammad yeah i don't know if he said
that i'll be honest
but you got to let the people who hate
it on you come around because they don't
know no better right it's like they're
just trying to survive and now you're
the version of survival so
i just got all these helix mattresses
from my house in the hamptons and it is
beautiful helix sleep as a quiz that
takes just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you why would you buy a mattress made
for someone else with helix you get a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you
sleep
everyone's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium firm mattresses mattresses great
for cooling you down if you're a hot
sleeper or great for spinal alignments
to prevent morning aches and pains and
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers like ben who has too much
weight and it hurts him
what what do you like about the helix
you know what i like about it it's
convenient yeah it is you know i want to
admit i'm going to be honest with you
okay i went to a mattress store
once to get a mattress for myself and i
went and i was looking at the different
mattresses
and
i i said to myself what am i doing here
i could be at home
eating
in my shower
and instead i'm here yeah walking around
this place
and i
and i and i started crying
on one of the
beds so what what are you what are you
gonna add to this
oh i was just gonna say that me and my
wife have one and we think it's lovely
i'm telling you right now folks they
have a 10-year warranty you get to try
it out for a hundred nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will helix even
has financing options and flexible
payment plans so a great night's sleep
is never far away just go to
helixsleep.com
tmd take their two minutes sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life so i'm telling you
i love it i mean it's a huge upgrade
over what i used to have delivery
setting it up was fast and easy it's
soft but really supportive i'm falling
asleep right away i'm sleeping well
everybody likes it my wife likes it
she likes it and many of the men that
she sleeps with like it too right just
me
no
she likes
it
and they like it
no
helix is offering up to 200 on all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.comd
he looks his offering up to 200 off full
mattress orders and two free pillows for
all our listeners helix sleep.com
tim day is michelle wolf a muslim now
for muslim fall
is she full full so interesting yeah but
you've seen it the long dresses and the
head coverings please tell me you're
joking no i'm not i'm just asking you
i did not know this michelle's a
brilliant joke writer yeah i believe she
might be full muslim
and that's great i love it i love that
culture i love quiet women and men who
smoke and are gay kind of a little yes
but also i was just asking if you heard
that i know i'm proud
i'm proud of her i i'm on there's like
an email that goes around when they get
one over and yeah
i'm i i didn't get that no i could be
wrong yeah i might be wrong but there
are
photos is there a better person to not
talk as much out loud
she has a voice
yeah the ideas are good if she was in
riyadh it would be
yeah walk around right keep walking yeah
it's interesting this is quiet it's the
thing about comics we all know each
other as comics and then we forget we're
people and then when people do things
that people do which is like convert to
religion or whatever right you're
surprised yeah but a voice is a choice
perhaps a little you know like you can
choose to lean in or lean out and it's
it's a choice like i lived in spain i
didn't speak with an english accent i
spoke with a spanish accent because i
made an effort that's true to care about
the people around me you love italy you
just got back with your wife you love
these areas
i mean i can't
30 minutes on michelle wolf
when this is more pressing she's gotten
in two years yes the thing is
the thing is i'm just curious i'm
curious i like islam i like you too um
uh you love italy with the wife
inshallah yeah
i hope you had inshallah amazing year i
hope you got some great gifts me too
this is great um yeah in italy how is
the pizza is it is it is it random that
like a girl with that voice dated the
guy whose name is most deaf well i think
he's the reason for the conversion
most death there we go yeah yeah
interesting you have to be all deaf to
deal with that
yeah but
most isn't most doesn't work
italy pizza
why like it it's so amazing
i question italians that moved here i
know yeah have you spent time
never i want to go tim i should go i
know it's the map i'm like the food it's
everything's beautiful no no it's it's
what you like i know it's everything's
lovely you you appreciate yes people who
have figured out things that's right
especially
life that's right and who spent
years trying to figure it out figuring
out warping a culture that's right like
wasp culture yes
is beautiful yes you go to the [ __ ]
what is it polo bar over on like 57th
street whatever it is everything's
worked out that's right and we know
we're putting on costumes that's right
it's like we're in [ __ ] venice
but it works and it's great and it's
comfortable and we love it right and
italy has done that with every aspect of
life yeah i'm i'm excited man like i
want to go and i know that i want to
take you yeah i'm being honest i would
like to be taken and
i will take you yeah please i'm gonna i
would love to you want to be taken bro i
will submit myself
to your financial whims to take me to
italy you you're the guy with the homes
i want to go
um i want to go badly i mean this
sincerely yeah i think you would [ __ ]
love it and i think they're like they're
little pockets for everything that you
could enjoy like if you want some like
like i was i don't love uh [ __ ] capri
there's a place capri right right and
it's beautiful it's awesome but it's
like um
it's a little like uh
it for me that's it it it's a little bit
too uh commercially commercialized like
um
look how big my yacht is look right what
is that what what would you call that
it's a little miami it's a little miami
a little bit too miami yeah for sure
but at the same time a little la too
it's a little l.a but it's like look at
me look what i can buy look right the
cool thing i liked about amalfi is it
wasn't that yes right it's like
i will enjoy this life and i don't care
if you are noticing me yeah it doesn't
matter yeah if you if you notice what
i'm doing great if not we don't care and
like it was cool to be at a hotel
because that's real confidence exactly
that's real confidence there's something
cool about that old money is cooler than
new money why because there's a there's
a mystery to it yes there's a mystery to
a guy that drives a beat-up car to a
massive estate there's a mystery to
people you know because the mystery is
why do you have confidence and people
don't have confidence right it's it's
why do you have confidence and then why
don't you care about what i think about
you yes because that's the currency that
runs the world yes so how have you opted
out yes how did you opt out of that
you're all ugly yeah real rich people
are gross they're inbred
they're they're they're very interesting
look they're like strange looking none
of them are hot hot people are state
schools right state school ucsb yeah not
even private like some private but like
a hot state school a university like a
you know a hot state school yes [ __ ]
basketball player is always going to be
better looking than a [ __ ] harvard
coder
but that that that you know as nick
mullen once brilliantly said inbred
syphilitic boy king
aesthetic of rich people of like kind of
malnourished weirdly put together uh
there's something so odd about it and
and they they do seem some of them like
they are another species yeah they might
be yeah but they understand life a
little bit yeah and they figured it out
and it's like while every one of these
billionaires like if they actually get
it yeah if they're not still trying to
like get the acceptance if they actually
get likes right
they go to [ __ ] montana and they just
look at mountains because there's
something that taps into that like like
it's it's hard to not feel some humility
when you're looking at a mountain that's
right it's hard to not feel some
humility when you're watching a
beautiful sunset on the side of a
[ __ ] you know bridge that was built
2000 years ago when you're in italy
you're uh places like that what do you
think they've figured out that americans
haven't they're a lot they're an older
society they're a much different society
understood like
boy [ __ ] had a time sure and
and then they got
rid of boy [ __ ] yes this is this is
some real [ __ ] you won't know some real
for sure we all
we all if we live long enough become
bigots even the most progressive version
that's right so like italy greek roman
empire early antiquity everybody's boy
[ __ ] everybody has a little [ __ ]
apprentice they [ __ ] them that's right
catholicism comes in
and cuts it out
they go hey we gotta stop [ __ ]
animals stop [ __ ] boys they got these
[ __ ] brothels that are in like
pompeii that are preserved well they got
the menu up there there's [ __ ]
animals there's kids there's whatever
you [ __ ] want right catholicism comes
in and then goes chill the [ __ ] out
now fast forward
two thousand years right catholic
catholics are the boy [ __ ] right and
it's like
i wonder if there's like historian
priests that are like
do you know how many boys would be
[ __ ] if it wasn't for us right like we
cut this whole [ __ ] out we decided let
us do it it got too far let us give us a
little let us run let us let's let us
run it it's like with the union spillage
what i never like you know i sometimes i
doubt religion but yeah beautifully
explained it
as it needed it stopped right it was it
got too far it was too free but then
also the catholic church was like let us
just do it a little
wouldn't you rather little than a lot
it's better a little or a lot a little
two boys [ __ ] or two thousand which do
you choose probably two
you know if those are the trouble if
those are the choices and by the way let
me switch it you're honestly what an
honest election
what an honest election you walk in
there and they go biden a hundred
thousand children [ __ ] let's go to the
next guy 65 000 children and you're
going to go oh my god 65 000. but then
you have to look at your wife and go but
this guy's not raising the gas tax she
goes but it's another 30 000 boys being
[ __ ] and it's like he goes yeah but
you know how much the gas tax is yeah
yeah but it is it isn't i don't drive a
boy isn't that interesting that for
whatever reason that's like what's run
that's what's run
this society for so long what is
catholicism boy [ __ ] boy [ __ ] it's
weird that that like pedophilia has
become you know what's the weirdest yeah
is you weren't gay so you were 25. well
i was getting rid of the [ __ ] balls
oh so you did boy [ __ ]
no no i was gay when i was younger but i
came out of the closet at 25. uh i acted
on it in my late teens early 20s okay so
you got a little piece of like what what
everybody has wanted so bad for years
well for decades for centuries no i was
under age i was of age oh so when you
were 18. yeah i was a va i was a human
you could have had like a like legal
years but i don't think that's what they
want i don't think it's boys [ __ ] boy
it's the older people [ __ ] the boy
you're probably right yeah it's that
you're probably right yeah it could have
something to do with a power dynamic
right and not actual like enjoyment no
it's definitely enjoyment but i think
it's like it's like i think it's part of
like the thing of like well we can do
anything else so we're a lot we've been
able to do everything else we've had
orgies we've had hookers we've had this
we've had that what's next so
do you think human beings need a
governor and by governor i mean the car
version not like the political version
the thing that stops your car from going
300 miles per hour
yes a bumper yes we've never we've never
replaced religion
with anything
um that has fulfilled people one of the
biggest problems i think with society
now is that technology is clearly our
new religion
everybody believes it money is the
religion well yeah but technology now
every everything's so plugged into the
technology that money is becoming
just part of technology when you say
technology you mean like social currency
you mean like likes i mean like well i
mean like
basically the entire
um
interdependent world that we've created
where what dictates our behavior does
technology dictate it or does it uh
acquiring resources dictated that's well
i think technology now is the way to
acquire resources because you can't get
a job without some type of profile yeah
you can't get a bank account you can't
get a whatever um so because we we all
have to buy into that system
um it becomes like a religion there's
sacraments there's things like that and
i don't think that religion is
fulfilling to people i think it it's
because it says nothing about your soul
says nothing about the afterlife right
it says nothing about uh how you should
treat other people it says nothing about
these cosmic questions it just says a
lot about how to
serve yourself yeah practically get by
and serve yourself and that's why we
have you know people have made this
point a million times whether you're on
the far left or the far right these are
all just belief systems it's religion
it's a way to get through life yeah and
to me it's like i i i think that like
you know we need to figure out
in our society if we can stay human
if there's a value to it or should we
speed up
just getting rid of this skin suit and
then and and then between the elon thing
yeah i mean because it there's an
inevitability to it it's not in our
lifetime but like like
can we
stay human beings yeah or are we just
gonna eventually go [ __ ] it
let's just take out all the
imperfections and upload our
consciousness and just become
the sci-fi movie yeah maybe that maybe
that happens i don't know yeah i guess
that
maybe that happens or maybe we have
another like
you know middle ages and everything goes
back to zero so that could be happening
that kind of yeah that's what i think
has probably happened probably on the
verge of many times we're maybe on the
cusp of going right back to the dark
ages i really believe that that has
happened multiple times in human history
big tech thinks they can decide for
everyone what's true and what's
misinformation question something on
youtube and you'll get deep platform
criticize our country's politics on
twitter and your posts will come with a
warning label we might not have we we
all might not have 44 billion dollars to
buy up tech companies and tell them what
to do
and they he didn't even do that but for
less than seven dollars a month you can
fight back against big tack using
expressvpn and this is true we all
use this vpn's important because you
know basically companies and governments
are all stealing your data and
information they're selling it you're
putting on lists and everything you know
expressvpn helps you anonymize much of
your online presence by hiding your ip
address unique identifier that every
device has it allows big tech to match
your activity back to you
that's why here at the tim dylan show we
use expressvpn on all the devices to
make it much more difficult for them to
exploit our data for their own profits
it's so easy to use expressvpn just just
tap once on a phone a computer to turn
it on that's all it takes to protect
your online privacy so if you don't
agree with big tech censorship then if
you want to take a stand visit
expressvpn.com tim dillon right now and
get three months of expressvpn free
that's kind of amazing that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s vpn.com tim dillon for
three months free express vp and three
months free expressvpn.com tim dillon we
use this in australia london we use it
everywhere we use it in london i express
vpn in london may
yeah
right we're using it in australia now
right
i'm telling you right now a lot of
people are doing these energy drinks and
coffee and it's not healthy
but literally our next partner has a
product that people i know and myself
are all starting to use every day it's
called athletic greens ag-1
you know a lot of people want better gut
health they want to feel better about
themselves they start to feel
sad or lackluster they are sleeping a
lot and
some of them have a glazed look in their
eye and it's disturbing it bothers
people
but
there's a way to fight back and get uh
at your best yeah how
with one delicious scoop of ag-1 you're
absorbing 75 high-quality vitamins
minerals whole food source superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens to help you
start your day right this special blend
of ingredients supports your gut health
nervous system immune system your energy
recovery focus and aging all of these
things
nice i mean you use it you personally
consume it yeah when do you take it
describe your routine i take mine in the
morning uh i don't like doing a coffee
or anything like that so i do some
robust tea and then i take the ag-1 and
how would you describe the taste
taste is totally fine you send it to
family and friends
i send it to my mom because she has
inflammation issues and this has helped
her what does she think of it she's big
two big thumbs up two way big thumbs up
it's lifestyle friendly whether you eat
keto paleo vegan dairy free or gluten
free contains less than one gram of
sugar so no gmos no nasty chemicals or
artificial anything while it still
tastes good you know it tastes good yeah
it does isn't it good yeah oh it's good
athletic greens is a climate neutral
certified company 2020 athletic greens
purchase carbon credits that supports
projects protecting the old growth rain
forest for every purchase they donate to
organizations helping to get nutritious
food to kids in need including the no
the no kid hungry here in the u.s and
2020 ag donated over 1.2 million meals
nice
just to my agent
right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition it's just one
scoop and a cup of water every day
that's it no need for a million
different pills and supplements to look
out for your health to make it easy
athletic greens is going to save you a
free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com tim dillon again
that's athleticgreens.com tim dillon to
take ownership over your health and pick
up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance
when you what's interesting about you
and what you seem to be really good at
is
trusting kind of your intuition in
situations where you go i'm gonna do
this thing that other people aren't
doing
and then other people in the beginning
they they all kind of go [ __ ] that and
they kind of and then they all adopt it
eventually and kind of copy you yeah and
you don't get annoyed at that because
it's the same way that i feel about the
you know people that were maybe shitty
to me it's just like this is what it is
i want you to succeed with it yeah right
it's the human nature of like please
succeed yeah like take everything
everything i do is for everybody take it
i'm 100 okay with it i want people to do
it i think it's better for comedy what's
better for comedy it's better for me
like it just it is better that more
people are good at comedy and there's
better more people do authentic versions
of comedy because then it sets a
standard of comedy that i think is
better for the audience i think now
you're gonna see people that are waking
up these institutions seem to possibly
be waking up and going you know what
we cannot just make shows for a small
sliver of people we've got to broaden
our our appeal if this works
yeah and it's up to the people if it
works but if it works yeah
there's no more notes on comedy that's
right yeah because if you have an actual
fan base and community that people who
actually support you
you could just do this and make more
money than you would make on netflix
that's right amazon or hulu whoever you
do with so
my my issue with the streamers is they
used to be able to give you eyeballs
yeah i did a netflix special i could get
more eyeballs posting on instagram and
youtube i did it because boomers need a
[ __ ] they need a logo boomers uh
organize the world with logos they're
like oh you on the jimmy kimmel show you
must be doing well right kids don't give
a [ __ ] kids came up on youtube they look
at youtube instagram tick tock kids are
actually in the weird way like they're a
little bit more artsy about it because
they've been creating content since
their kids too well they're also they
care about the creator they're deeply
skeptical of institutions because
they've every single one has failed them
right the government the state everybody
the church they they've seen all this
[ __ ] lie to them over and over again no
no they also came up with the real yeah
so like we didn't come up with the real
right meaning like we saw just shows you
know sitcoms on nbc abc whatever it was
that's all we knew so we were like
that's content right then we saw people
make [ __ ] on youtube and we were like oh
you can say that like yeah the different
institutions had this like vice had a
moment remember when vice was putting
out these documentaries initially not
when they were bought out and they
became like the [ __ ] watered-down
version
but the initial vice stuff you were like
what the [ __ ] is going on like are these
people doing heroin and why is this in
like i'm watching some guy in the
ukraine who's missing teeth like you're
talking to the taliban like what the
[ __ ] is happening right and it cut
through everything yeah it was immediate
right and that's kind of what youtube
did and that's what it did for creatives
on youtube and it's not just stand-up
it's literally everybody everybody so
you're a product of this yes you know
what i mean so it's like
once you hear this
you can't go back to hey this is bob and
the cactus in the morning and uh you
can't do it it's hard it seems so
fraudulent it seems fake so i think what
happens right now is like
back in the day like netflix could make
you a star if you were funny not
everybody but if you were funny can make
you star yeah now
they can't provide the eyeballs people
have lost confidence in the algorithm
because everything they suggest is a 90
because they make everything that's
right youtube don't make [ __ ] right so
if it sucks they don't suggest it right
if it's good they suggest it yeah right
so
right now we don't trust the netflix
algorithm so they can't give you the
people and if they can't pay you the
money for the people not being there
yeah you might as well do it on your own
now i don't know if this works if it
does [ __ ] work and there's another
option please believe a network is not
going to tell you you have to cut a joke
because they know you could go make
money elsewhere right and they're going
to have to pay us more because they know
what we can actually make
i'll know what i'm worth right sunday
i'll know what i'm worth as a comedian
right who's putting out a special right
very few comics no no they might know
what they're worth like for woke points
the vast majority don't no
yeah for sure i have a lot of
conversations with people that are in in
a business and they're
you know they're unable to fully
be honest openly about the way they feel
but they're also kind of like you know
they they look at people and they go i'd
love to work with whoever fill in the
blank name but i can't because my hands
are tied um that does seem to be
changing a little bit where they're
they're now like hey you know netflix
lost 80 of their stock price right
they've had to fire hundreds of people
maybe thousands of people um a lot of
these streamers are are cutting back a
lot of the things that we grew up
watching have been rendered completely
irrelevant now you know whether it's the
emmys or the academy awards like people
have lost confidence in the entire
business
the entire [ __ ] business which was
one of the only businesses that america
through and through dominated no matter
what we had zero competition we were the
place you got movies music tv
entertainment and you know there were
some other people that were doing their
things in the uk and britain and that
was great too yeah i mean i'm sure
there's other you know the asian
countries have their own thing um
but america was yet let's not pretend
that we didn't dominate for years with
that you know um and now we've fallen
off hard
and what do you mean by that i don't i
don't think we've fallen off i think our
movies suck our comedy movies are top
gun unbelievable one that's one marvel
movie or talk about comedy
whatever it is you know what i'm saying
it's the same
it's the same kind of it's the same kind
of movie when's the last good comedy
you've seen in a movie theater when's
the last time you've went oh my god i
have to bring all my friends to watch a
comedy that you have seen in a movie
theater let me think about that you
shouldn't have to yeah in 1997 you
didn't have to i don't watch a lot of
comedies in the theaters to be honest
with you but for sure well there aren't
many i'll tell you there's not many well
you don't want to watch that's because
they don't think they work abroad and
right now without the details
dude it's all need to have enough also
because they're terrified jokes have to
be mean they somebody's got to be the
butt of a drone okay okay
this goes back to the same thing with
yeah where it's like the fear
is reduced by the promise of success
yeah okay yeah so
if they know that a movie's gonna make
crazy money yeah it's worth taking the
risk these five million dollar comedies
that were amazing the hangover the first
one absolutely [ __ ] hilarious
that's worth it five million dollars
that's it look at look at the success of
comics on platforms like youtube and
patreon look at the success of look at
the daily wire so the daily wire has
made hundreds of millions of dollars in
subscriptions yes and i'm not saying
their movies are great but i'm saying
there is a hunger for something that
isn't woke [ __ ] and yet the people
still don't make it they cancelled
roseanne and i'm not saying rosianne was
right to say what she said but they
canceled roseanne after she had the
biggest opening in in like recent memory
because it's not solely about the money
if it was they would be making more
content for people that voted for donald
trump the fact that they're not doing
that it's it really is ideological it's
not simply about the money i think that
there are definitely people in this
country that are not being served
content that satisfies their beliefs
right and there are companies that are
absolutely you know everything that's
coming out now the movie fire island
is about gay guys that go to fire island
and to [ __ ] and somehow can't have fun
because everyone's racist
can you imagine that that's exactly what
it's about it's about gay people who go
to fire island to do molly and [ __ ] yeah
and it's not fun because everyone is a
big classist racist
that's what things are and that didn't
do well
i don't know what it did it's not nobody
knows what anything does anymore but
like
you know these types of movies where
it's like we're gonna teach you a lesson
yeah that people are tired of that yeah
that's i think one of the reasons that
these companies are people are going
[ __ ] for you yeah your 40 is good
absolutely phenomenal really great
brilliant really good gay as [ __ ] not
funny super gay it's very gay
thoughtful yes successful yes the world
stops everybody watches it it's very
good a lot of people do yeah
it it dominates the conversation yes
actually to be honest with you hbo is
no disney's doing well too hbo gets
streaming disney also gets streaming and
i think that's the thing like
netflix just fundamentally don't
understand like they don't understand
what what makes a streamer successful
right you know what i mean like it's
very simple yeah you need
laundry tv so the [ __ ] that's just on in
the background yeah and then you need a
scripted show that people cannot wait to
see what happens next week and transform
next season yeah that's it for sure my
wife goes to sleep every single night to
[ __ ] harry potter yeah you need
something some people it's the office
but they got rid of the office yeah they
got rid of let's see the friends yeah
that is your core yeah you can't get rid
of that what i'm just what i'm looking
forward to is like i would like to see
some more
stuff out there
that is
not
predominantly about
but you why do you want this from
institutions that that aren't good at it
because they have because they were good
at it yeah but you you know they're bad
in these institutions well because no
one can do it on their own you cannot
make game of thrones on your own daily
wire the daily wire did it on their own
yeah but i don't want it to be a
right-wing lunatic either like we don't
want that either
you don't want ben shapiro to make game
of thrones no i don't wanna i don't
wanna you don't want him to do it i
don't wanna hand come on this may be a
good point but i don't wanna hand the
entertainment industry to uh just a
political ideologue
is a right-wing establishment did it so
a wing can do it and middle of the row
can do it it's possible
was funny because she had kurt metzger
yes and jesse klein and all these people
that would fight every day in the
writers room yes and they'd have
arguments and they'd trash you know yes
and that show they had some really
really good sketches because they
allowed that collision of ideas to
happen they had brilliant [ __ ]
writers from what i hear yeah but they
didn't agree it's good and now all of
the shows there's when they did agree
that kurt sketch was right it was funny
right that's really simple
when they all agreed that what kurt said
was funny it was funny yeah there seems
to be a litmus test now for people to
work in this business as writers and
that to me
is because they haven't failed enough
eventually they're going to fail they're
going to lose enough money and then
everything's going to translate that's
what we hope we hope we hope we hope
that that's happening it's happening you
see it right now you see the offers that
are going on like specials from
different companies they're not offering
what they used to offer no it is going
down significantly significantly okay so
eventually they're not even going to be
able to offer that right and
they're putting all their [ __ ] on
youtube anyway yeah youtube is you
cannot [ __ ] with youtube that's right
youtube is inevitable it's it youtube
will take out tick tock tick tock is
days are numbered interesting youtube
shorts
is
i'm never wrong you were right about
netflix it took years but i was right
about austin
what did you say about austin don't go
when did you say that i said don't go to
austin i'm not moving to austin oh i
never heard you say yeah what is it the
other one [ __ ] the the talking app or
some [ __ ] you were writing about
clubhouse
anyway i've mentioned that many times
that you're right
yeah youtube you just can't it's fine
eventually they'll just get tick-tock
out of here instagram will probably days
are numbered that's probably gone soon
but like youtube shorts they just have
all the data you're talking about google
here like they actually understand how
to make uh what is it software hardware
they don't know how to do they're nerds
they don't have to make glasses that are
cool i don't need to take [ __ ] style
tips from a nerd right but i need you to
make sure my phone works right i need
you to make sure that my life is easy
and they know how to do that [ __ ] yeah
and if they don't know how to do it they
buy the one that's going to do it so
youtube knocks tick tock out of here
interesting yeah youtube shorts watch
what you watch on youtube now what's the
no no for sure what's the timeline on
that
three years interesting maybe less i'm
giving myself a long yeah a runway there
yeah yeah interesting yeah you might be
ryan youtube isn't it's yeah i mean
they're they're look at everybody that
we know that's famous now they're on
youtube there's not a single person
that's new that's famous that is not on
youtube yeah that's true like even the
tick tockers are on youtube they have to
be right youtube is the is the new tv
it's the new tv it's the new radio like
this is radio this is tv this is
everything it's just how we consume yeah
it's just right there it's curated
perfectly for us like if they suggest
you a video and you think you won't like
it who the [ __ ] are you right you don't
know you right do you know what i mean
you gotta trust me they know you just
trust us yes i got recommended a video
of yours a couple times yeah right and i
forget what it was and it was like two
or three times it happened and i was
like
yeah there's something in this that i'm
going to really [ __ ] love yeah
and immediately it was me complimenting
him no it was just me saying you were
right this guy was just like yeah i
don't know what was this thing and then
it was like you going oh yeah it was
right no it was you just [ __ ] being
hilarious like you are man yeah and it's
i don't know i i just love it i love the
ability that this can you know provide
for ourselves i think the big transition
for us obviously with stand-up is like
right now we're giving everything away
for free on youtube how do we find a way
to monetize these things because making
a [ __ ] special is expensive you know
cost hundreds of thousands you know this
it cost hundreds of thousands of dollars
to make a great quality special right
you can't make that if you're going to
give it away for free so how do you find
a way to monetize it is this the way
maybe but there's going to be ways where
we can do it and then deliver it right
to the people
people support it there's laws in oregon
uh where people pay to
uh end their life end of life what's it
called you you it's euthanasia
assisted suicide euthanasia yeah i want
to do a special in and i'm not even
kidding in oregon where we take a bunch
of people that want to die yeah and put
them in a theater whereas after my
special is over
we kill them all right but not kid they
wanted that you did this in portland i'm
dead serious i would shoot every one of
you yeah yeah like as i would be
execution because they want to die
and my whole thing is like come to my
special and then you would the state
would pay me or whatever you know i have
t-shirt guns at my shows i don't but i i
know that you do crazy [ __ ] i will bring
guns are they dangerous t-shirt guns if
they're close enough but i i don't want
i don't want t-shirts in it yeah you
want real things if it was portland i
would do it i just want i just want it
to be peaceful
for people because i do believe it's
compassionate to let someone in their
life yeah i just want to do it like for
that would be a way that i'd find an
easy way out though like suffer
suffer with the rest of us like wait you
just tap the [ __ ] out it's a good point
but i also think there's so much going
on out there now with the you know
traffic and such that you know hey
get those ambulances off the road
you know we've got too much going on as
as a people there's just too much
happening you think that's yeah i mean
there's just too much i think that like
society is going to collapse in this
very interesting way where everyone's
talking about
um you know like the we're we're we're
really starting to see
it's just you're so funny uh and i know
you hate success you're you're missing
you're so successful you you have all
these points that's successful people
think you're amazing
i mean is that a lot of homelessness
doesn't everyone have three i think who
do you know that doesn't have three
houses i'm not even kidding i've never i
don't know one person that doesn't have
three this is what it itself literally
you're like this many people love me
society's falling apart no if something
is going wrong it's not and it's all
going to come you don't you don't think
there's you know you because you're
you're relentlessly positive doesn't
that get exhausting no
doesn't it seem insane yeah it does seem
crazy when you drive through listen when
you drive through all the homeless and
the tents and the wildness do you not
think a little bit that there's issues a
little
no
interesting but that will seem to most
people like you're a full entrepreneur
why do you think they're issues because
there are people living in like [ __ ]
tent there are people who have nothing
yes but the fact that there are people
who have nothing to do you have three
houses shut the [ __ ] up about the tents
i put those
my whole point though what do you mean
you know what are you talking about me
having me having houses doesn't make
everything else i'm in the house
i just
why do i have to put them in the house
because you're you're saying that that's
an issue but it is an issue but you
don't want to do anything about it no i
don't want to just take the sociopathway
which is there is no issue because i pay
a lot of taxes to have a dealt with oh
you you think about the money you pay in
taxes well the money we pay in taxes is
so that those issues can be alleviated
is that what it is well why are we
paying it because the government's a
mafia
well all mafias at least took care of
people did they a little bit did they
there were times
how did they take care of them well they
provided certain protection for
businesses or illegal businesses yeah if
you did if you're a flower shop you just
call the cops if somebody got the water
they would help the wife out a little
bit yeah they did take care of people
our do the way our government is
constituted as a mafia that doesn't take
care of anybody exactly that's the
government but you don't think that's a
problem and if you ruffle their this is
the funniest [ __ ] about like what's
happening with elon right now like elon
like i have no problem with your
solution yeah which is just check out
because
let me clarify and i don't think there's
a problem with it it's not just checkout
and obviously if we're being facetious
here like i recognize there's [ __ ]
there's problems etc 100
but
in terms of like like positivity it's
not like i'm like and i'm not even
claiming to be a good person i'm not
even a good person no i know i know i'm
just saying
get it out of my face yeah
yeah i mean like can we help the people
but also help me you want to help them
so you don't have to deal with the guilt
i want it's not even guilt it's gross
yeah it smells it's bad yeah it's it's
let's figure it out yes it's the back to
the beginning of figuring it out yeah
i'm not mother teresa who also wasn't
mother teresa that's a whole nother
thing and a whole nother point
she loved poverty not the poor hitchens
wrote a whole thing it's true she loved
the poverty yeah anyway uh the the the
point is i just you know
do you think this thing goes on forever
you just said we're on the verge of the
dark age no what i think is
you just said we're going life happens
it is what it is how often are we gonna
say it is what it is and then not
believe it life happens you get to
create
your story on top of that
yes yes that's true i want to enjoy this
little time i have here so i'm going to
create a story that allows me to enjoy
it the most the way i enjoy it is
realizing how dead it is buddy and how
much is decay is your family not [ __ ]
up or anything like don't you have
enough they're [ __ ] up like bad or no
not bad
i think it's bad enough
you know it's not bad enough if you're
like worried about tents
because if you had enough [ __ ] up [ __ ]
in your family yeah you would you
wouldn't worry about the tents you would
be like oh my god my my my mind my heart
my body is so concentrated like what's
happening over here
that i don't have enough for this how am
i how am i gonna worry about my family i
have three houses i have multiple
businesses yeah yeah yeah are you
mentally ill and worried about my family
what are you talking about
my family who's paying me to worry about
my family i have a balenciaga sweatshirt
three x this is my favorite personality
three times we need to do something
about society not me but somebody no
governments those government people need
to do something about society who's
corrupt the government no no no no no no
no no no no i need to do something it's
a false choice because you seem like a
psychopath when you drive by the tents
and you go there's no problem here no i
never said it's crazy i never said it
you said that several minutes ago
i'm also a liar okay but the point is
this i'm a psychopath
tim i'm a psychopath all i'm saying no
one is refuting now nobody is refuting
that and i'm not even saying like
we're very similar in the sense like we
got to listen
now you're like i'm also a cycle no no
this is why it works we have to be
selfish to do our jobs
because listen yeah i spend years and
years getting funny and it's hard i have
lots of empathy i know i'm i'm meaning
this sincerely it's [ __ ] up i also
live in new york i don't see the tenth
thing as much as you guys all i'm saying
is that there's some weird cracks
like
i don't know if i can say that you can
yeah shane
i'm just i'm just saying that things are
a little
i i think it's beautiful i don't see the
tents i go to st louis and i see east st
louis and i'm like overwhelmed because
yes i know there's people who who made
it out of east st louis yes and it's
like oh my god like what's amazing it is
that that accomplishment is mind-blowing
i grew up in east st louis literally not
even kidding i grew up in east st louis
my family i'm not even i don't even talk
about this on the show you should i was
part of the gang in east st louis yeah
yeah and i was the only white gay openly
gay guy in the gang and no one cared
because why it wasn't about that because
i shot a woman in the head once that was
going to rat on us for selling drugs to
her daughter because her daughter were
overdeed i shot her in the head after
that everyone respected me and i made it
out yeah because they
passed all that other [ __ ] yes
i agree i'm just i'm we're agreeing yes
i'm just saying there's a lot of
problems out there yeah and we should
just talk about them at dinner
but at where like like a prime or like
uh i like the place
i'm just saying this is my that's my
[ __ ] is like what do you want me to what
what makes you feel better like does it
make you feel better to acknowledge the
problems and do nothing about it i just
don't want your drug no no no what's
your drugs it's not my drug tell me your
how do you deal with it
i felt bad that people were getting
bombed yes but did you sure how bad
oh i mean hence bad like give me uh
well no tense is right in my thing
because that's the thing like if you
were really honest about it it's
inconvenient to you
like and that's the real thing ruining a
very very pretty city and now you own
pieces of that city and it's a problem
and you don't want the tents there and
is that wrong
there is no right or wrong bro that's
the thing it's like i'm not saying
that i'm going to bring
like fentanyl addicts into my house yeah
i'm not saying i'm bringing mentally
disturbed people into my house yeah what
i'm saying is seeing them run around the
streets
is not good yes
here's the thing about our good friend
steve will do it
steve will do it
is a
autistic
multi-millionaire
who
does great things for people
and there's many young what people on
the spectrum now that go how am i going
to
get [ __ ]
drive lambos
have 400 000 watches
like all the things that make life good
and our friend steve will do it has
accomplished that
has steve ever read a book who knows can
he read a book is it important
the reality is
did he graduate school did he go to
school
doesn't matter
does he know
all or any of the presidents
doesn't matter
he's got a rock on the wrist
knee-deep in them hoes he has one
girlfriend but still the point is he
could be if he wanted to be
so if you're an autistic person out
there and you don't know in the
neurodivergent community many of them
are fans of the show yes
and if you're in the neurodivergent
community and you want to work for a
crypto gambling website
and like live on a speedboat somewhere
between miami and the bahamas
and just
use kids for cancer as a shield
while you dart from island to island
making deals with tribal warlords
look gold and support steve will do it
on youtube please
support steve will do it on youtube
because you know he's a real character
he's a character this guy
and he's done a lot for the neuro
atypical community the neurodivergent
community
where
um he's a very
brilliant man
um
and he's very interesting i don't even
know who that is that a young photo of
him eating his hand oh yeah i love his
abby on uh well show me that i don't
even know what that is uh here hold on
look how happy he is just popping the
champagne with that sombrero on his head
he's so happy
he's so happy don't you want to be that
hey listen
neuro neuro diversion people if you play
your cards right this is in your future
he's having a great time yeah he is he's
enjoying himself
he's like a legend like he's like the
best thing that [ __ ] where does he
live
somewhere florida and florida i don't
know where but the point is i think i
know but i don't want to say it it's a
you know
but he's the best thing that that swamp
ever produced this guy
he's part of that no whatever happened
to that other knelt guy what does he do
now he's driving lyft
steve will do it on youtube is that
what's there's nothing wrong with that
you know it's a good job you got to put
the uh
thing up for the covet you know the
plastic um
go to stevewillduit.com i'll tell you
right now folks it's really good because
he's he's he's
wait what i promoted a website we don't
even know if it's real
what do you mean you said go to
stevewelldoit.com no i mean steve will
do it on instagram
what are we being paid
for
[Laughter]
who is this
that's not steve
that's not our friend steve who the [ __ ]
is this guy i don't know ma'am we can
talk to him on whatsapp go i don't want
to go back to the youtube this is
scaring me
looks like michael aquino looks like the
colonel oh yeah he does from dude to
johnny
steve as a new video out it says i
helped mexican families at home depot
cops called
can we watch that what is he doing here
he's picking the families up and i think
taking them to work this is [ __ ]
heroic and patriotic
in all the videos how many changes he
wears
he keeps getting us demonetized because
of his music is that true yeah is that
true yeah sometimes
well can we can we can we just play it
without them without the music without
the music how does he get away oh
because they don't make any money no
he's not monetized yeah right
so here's an mma fight that they went to
okay
okay
yeah yeah yeah very good
uh
here's it back in my i love how much
they love florida it's great they're
just handing money yeah like
can you just
i want to hear what they're doing now
yeah i think it's going to be music
though
all right so we're here at home depot
we're trying to change mexicans lives
outside of home depot but the thing is
everyone here is on their ass where's my
money everywhere
but we go inside home depot
he pays me in like some like
fake coin
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
sir are you mexican
no you mexican mexican yeah you kind of
look like doctor strange i get that all
the time
that's insane
hi are you mexican
why what is that i just wanna know
you won
the member
i'm gonna ask you to leave this store
thank you are you mexican it doesn't
really matter gonna ask me to leave this
door
let's hope the police is mexican
miami pd
yes nice here young's recording
what's up doctor strange what's up man
what are you guys up to uh we're just
gonna have some money oh my god wow
thank you so much that's awesome holy
[ __ ] all right hold on
okay well that's nice they're giving
money to mexican people see this is what
aoc should be doing
this is what she claims she cares about
and yet
is she in this video where's she hey
where's aoc
in the
video
with our friends uh steve will do it and
the nalc
collective
go to steve we'll do it uh on on youtube
please thank you goodbye it's stunning
to people
when they see the way we've created this
society where people are running around
and screaming
and going crazy you know what's crazy
about you is the the economy is all fake
it's not real
everything else to you yeah is real
once you apply the economy thing to
everything yeah
i don't i don't disagree with you
i'm just saying these people get upset
about the president and they're upset
about everything it's like i'm not
saying
i'm not saying you get upset but you can
find your joy you know you can notice
things say again you can notice things
that's all hey hey bro you can notice
things listen you don't have to get bent
out of shape hold on hold on right you
you notice bro i know hey hey i noticed
you're you're an ally bro the way you
notice bro if you are driving down the
street and there's a guy in front of
your car and he's taking a [ __ ]
you can you can go yeah
yeah interesting yeah that's all i'm
doing yeah i'm just noticing it and i'm
going i wonder what this means yeah and
i wonder
what this says about where we are at
this time and what will then happen in
the future yeah it's kind of academic
what can we notice like do we notice the
uyghurs let's notice them dude i love
noticing we noticed the uyghurs all the
time let's notice them i i do could
would you be able to notice one
at all like when you saw one would you
be able to notice it and be like that's
a uyghur well where is the uyghur
exactly i mean is it a uyghur like if
you showed me a uyghur in a camp i might
go that's a weird if there was a uyghur
in like whataburger i don't know if i'd
pick out a uyghur and whataburger yeah
where is the uyghur that's a fun game
can you bring something up then can you
get a where's wild though but it's where
is
[Laughter]
but i just all i like to know is notice
no we're noticers bro but i like to
notice isn't that our job
isn't it
yes so let's notice let's get a uyghur
let's go is that uh let's see here let's
get a uyghur up here we go that's
michelle wolf
no
the uyghurs look fine they look great
that looks handsome
well-fed but i'm also a fan of china i
believe in one china
i know i believe taiwan's [ __ ] i don't
want to hear about taiwan i believe in
one china and i believe they should take
over america but can we notice them can
we know this can you notice taiwan can
we notice because they're being bombed
yes yeah i believe in one china yes
taiwan does not exist it's a part of
china it is right it is a part of china
it is let's cut the [ __ ] let's
put it let's cut the [ __ ] because to me
i believe in one try not shout out to
president g yeah and i have said yeah
rogan took a deal with spotify i want to
take a deal with china it's the same
company interesting i want to be the
first podcast on china's new streaming
service called one china
and the the the episode the first
episode is me
commentating watching hong kong get
stormed
interesting one china one china
una one
uno i wanna know who no one i wanna be
with the winners yes
do you think they got it you think they
figured it out have you noticed anything
about that
they they they figured a few things out
which is they run a country like a
corporation
yes and that's something there's
something
it's hard we do too we just we just
believe we need these problems we do too
for sure it's the most hilarious thing
for sure the course of america is
decided in four-year increments no it's
crazy it's crazy but the fact that what
elon is going through right now is just
so funny because it's like he thought he
was bigger than the system yeah like he
he really for a second was like i think
i could do whatever i want yeah and then
they just had to remind him like you
know how your dad like [ __ ] his
daughter right like we're just gonna let
people know
that you're like your dad [ __ ] his
daughter i meant i have kids i met him
and i met him and i i'll tell you this i
thought he was interesting he's clearly
really bright yeah um good noticing you
know he's also uh
he's a carnival barker
he likes the fame he likes the attack
that's what he wants of course that's
what he wants did you see trump's roast
yeah i mean the guy's still got it he
still hasn't the guy's still got it no
question bring it i mean it is he did it
on his own [ __ ] app yeah but it was
so true social [ __ ] funny yeah that i
imagined him saying it i'm actually sad
i didn't get to hear him say right
because if he said that like if he was
just on one of like the [ __ ] fox news
or something like that yeah
do you have the actual thing yeah right
here oh yeah great when elon musk came
to my it came to the white house asking
me for help on all of his many
subsidized projects whether it's
electric cars that don't drive long
enough driverless cars that crash or
rocket ships to nowhere
without which subsidies he'd be
worthless and telling me how he was a
big trump fan and a republican i could
have said quote drop your knees in beg
and he would have done it i mean trump
is still
the guy sharp sharp sharp you think he
runs again he wants to i think he has to
right yeah they'll put him in prison if
he doesn't win do you think he'll win
yeah
i don't think people know who desantis
is i i mean that's an opportunity like i
think the average american has no
[ __ ] clue who desantis is and they're
there does it were you at all do you
think if trump wins yeah
democracy goes not that we have a
democracy but the fake democracy we have
goes bye-bye like no if nothing happens
if he wins or he doesn't win the only
problem is like people will be more
agitated and upset so they're just gonna
be annoyed and he doesn't know how to
lead he just knows how to win like he'll
probably win because he's good
does it worry you that he
you know he seems to be a guy that
doesn't necessarily respect
any of the electoral results that don't
say he wins yeah like if he's a guy that
just goes hey listen
uh you know i won and that's it and yeah
if he staffs all these positions with
loyalists that say certify it and go
yeah we're not certifying it unless he
won um that worries me a bit you
actually think that it could turn into a
dictatorship yes
i think people want it m2 or something
like that no but they would they he'd
pass it down to the to whoever it was to
the the his dimitri medvedev
maybe maybe you you might pass it down
to you no no no no no it yeah i mean you
just got to be such an abject loser to
want to be president like what a [ __ ]
loser but it seems kind of fun no no no
if you if you had a root there you're
telling me you're not doing it i'm not
even close i would know no one believes
that no one ever would not no one
believes you right i'll do it no do it
i'll do it i'll clean up them
i could see you doing well
no i'm not right and i honestly think
you have to be an absolute loser what do
you think when i said logan paul could
win i think he could win yeah i think he
could for sure yeah
i think those guys those social media
guys
at the end of their run they understand
the game and logan's logan's a smart guy
smart guy smart guy
rave
he's at his age
in his 30s when he's ready to run he's
going to have this database of all these
people yeah he's going to be able to
have that trump effect where he
communicates directly with the voters
yeah i think that could be you know i
think you should run them
you know jake paul said i could be uh i
don't know secretary of something [ __ ]
the secretary you want
you want to run him well yeah i want to
i want to i want to help him win i've
always said i would quit comedy to help
jake or logan paul on him run to
controlling their mind
[Laughter]
right
no like what's the guy's name
uh stone is that his name roger roger
stone like you know you understand the
game more than these people and you
understand what works and i'm not
talking about like how the [ __ ]
electoral college works you don't
understand what people's mind
me and you if we had a candidate you
don't think we could get them far i
didn't say that i wouldn't we run
somebody we could get them so
far i mean tim if we're really smart we
run opposite candidates well that's true
but i mean like we could really have an
have an impact and run people tim who
says we won't do this one day you know
what i mean i think it's a great idea
but i would only do it because my guy
could be like [ __ ] the tents and your
guy could be like everybody gets a tent
all everyone has look under your chair
and what's great
and what's great about that is that
people will go along with both of them
because they both sound good like
somebody in the car goes well no
everyone has a tent now it's actually
good so people would actually
it's interesting what does your wife
think about this business because i know
that
she's you keep it private and she's not
really like she's not she doesn't want
to be famous or anything what is she
loves the food though she's really an
absolute she loves but she's also like
um
you know she's i i would say more than a
foodie you know she's like you know she
she cooks she's also developing this
platform yes blisters red peppers or
blisters it's actually a brilliant idea
actually it's just like for sure like
the idea that this one-stop shop for
like
everything that you need for food not
only just recipes recommendations but
also like turning into like e-commerce i
like really yeah yeah she's a sharp girl
she just got her mba from nyu like she's
she's on it you know for sure but like
what does she think about this she
doesn't want to be in a single [ __ ]
picture she doesn't want she doesn't
want like the internet scrutiny she
doesn't want she understands that and
sees what like i go through and other
people do and she's just you know she's
sensitive and she doesn't want that it's
which is [ __ ] great it's a lot you
know forget about that is [ __ ] great
if you were married to someone that
wanted to spotlight you would have to
get them to convert to islam islam
immediately immediately immediately
where do you want to if when you uh when
when you leave new york yes do you ever
think of buying a place eventually down
the line outside of the country where
would i do it yeah because i know you
feel like a guy that's you you almost go
you guys
interesting yeah
yeah kabum you're new to commodores your
mom well there's a thing with kabul okay
there's a lot of religious people there
mum um they want to have a comedy club
and i'm gonna bring it's gonna be kill
tony mom
and then you you'll go on and then
andrew schultz mom he's [ __ ] a beast
he's a savage mom
and we'll call it the couple comedy
connection mom that's [ __ ] crazy mom
um
no where else would i go dude i love
miami dude i mean i'm just trying to get
you to move to miami i want to go i like
it so here's the thing we do miami look
the dream i have to start if i bring up
sukiyana and hit image oh yeah if i move
to miami here is how i would have to
start dressing and i want i want sukiana
and hit image this is how i dress if i'm
in miami yes or yes right there right
here right there that's that is how i
dress in miami yeah
oh yeah or bring up saucy santana oh
saucy santana saucy santana i'm gonna
have to start dressing yeah if i move to
miami i'd have to start dressing
like saucy santa there you go right
there
right there i'm going to get that bbl
yeah
that's right now miami's fire miami's
great love my me couldn't write a joke
there the entire time because it's too
fun it's there's too much joy there's
nothing to push back on like that's
right there's no angst there's no people
yapping about dumb [ __ ] it's just people
trying to enjoy their family have fun
party yeah
drink
and that's a very hard thing to be if
you're upset at that you're an [ __ ]
yeah if there's some chick with [ __ ]
purple armpit hair screaming about [ __ ]
outside of a [ __ ] 18t building right
it's it's fun for me right to remove her
anger from that's right that is that's
right that's like fundamental you can
write jokes here here yes yes because
people are ridiculous ridiculous
ridiculous in a bad way that's right
ridiculous in a good way is miami is
miami that's right and the fact that
like people criticize dude the fact that
people criticize florida dude right it's
like everybody there is happy they're
happy so it's like
well they're they're happy but there's a
point where they od on it so it's
god bless god bless them but for us you
want to help them in portland they're
too [ __ ] to do it themselves in miami
they go in but it's bad for us for our
job
why to be over to too happy oh not 100
yeah no no i i like so that was the
hardest thing that's why i moved
everybody back to new york it was like i
can't write jokes here and i love this
too much so we have to go back but the
ideal situation is probably
we do winner
we do like eight months in miami yeah
and then
i love new york in the summer [ __ ]
amazing i like everyone leaves the city
it's like you're on yeah it's amazing
that's what people don't get yeah the
city's the best in the [ __ ] summer
right it's there's an energy it's like
the people that don't have enough money
to leave are there and those are kind of
the cool people anyway right and it's
like it's it's young it's [ __ ]
exciting and there's not as much traffic
right it's just i love so i would that
would be
a dream man
why don't you you hate the hamptons you
hate it no i don't hate the hamptons
this is like you hate whites
yeah
yeah
no like i don't know don't you don't you
want to like when i was boring
when i was it's the same thing as capri
it's like everybody kind of needs to
[ __ ]
let's create manhattan outside of
manhattan it's like what's well [ __ ] we
leave manhattan for it like because it's
a it's a gray [ __ ] brick hell that
you need to believe
you need to leave it every now and then
dude it is you need to leave it you need
to to look at like there's no sunset in
manhattan and isn't that crazy like
imagine growing up without seeing that
leaving the city and i love the city
it's so much but i'm from the island so
we always have those different
perspectives yeah like you are like
giannis yeah samaril you're city kids
yes i'm a suburbs kid yes so it's like a
different thing i appreciate the city
but the city for me was always go enjoy
it and leave but you like i don't know
like
like you
you would like nantucket and [ __ ] right
like you like this like old white money
you're into that well sure so it's dave
portnoy yes he is dave is [ __ ] you
should have dave on here have you got i
don't care about buddy no dave is funny
i know but i don't care i only you
you're a friend of mine i really don't
like having guests yeah because i don't
care what anyone has to say about
anything and you know what i mean and
you're my friend so i like arguing with
you and stuff but like i have no yeah i
have no need oh wow okay that's good and
i bet that people probably prefer just
you talking yeah i just have no need to
yeah like i'd have to be like so what a
jaw did you just when did you yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you can't
do it yeah i can't even do it yeah yeah
yeah i can't even do it yeah unless like
i gave them all truth serum
and yeah having the i gave them like
sodium pentathol and i went all right
let me let's go yeah what are you really
you know yeah but no no nantucket for me
um i get a kick out of and this is why i
like
old rich people yeah but you like old
american rich
there's another level to that
in the south of europe yeah i like old
european rich too i think you need to
indulge in that here's i would love to
yeah
what i like about them is they are
funny a little eccentric they're
ridiculous people um
it's a secret very small club
they don't
really
parade themselves around as much they
are kind of insulated and insular
and there it's interesting like you know
i remember
me and him were eating ice cream in
montauk once and my friend
my friend works for a guy that i think
just last year made like a billion
dollars and i laughed i just looked at
ben and i said there's something funny
to me
about last year
earning a billion dollars yeah i just
started laughing yeah i couldn't even
explain it there was just something it's
something innately funny so to me these
families that have been so rich for so
long
uh and they have all these weird feuds
and
inbred infighting yeah secrets and [ __ ]
and they shape the world you know not
all of it not everything but there's
shape a lot of it dude it's actually
hard to but you nepotism going yeah it
is no like i mean that for surely yeah
kids are retards that is the problem the
kids are retards so like the knicks for
example james dolan owns the knicks yeah
you're familiar with the dolan family
for sure
the board of the directors for the
knicks like five of them have the last
name dolan right now the knicks haven't
won since the 70s yeah now are you
telling me james dolan that the best way
to increase shareholder profits
the most effective people just happen to
be in your family right there's nobody
outside of your family that might be
more qualified
to make me [ __ ] money right nobody so
that the crazy like that's the thing
about
mafia exists it's so weird like mafia
needs violence right because nepotism
creates idiots yes if the mafia could
just outsource talent yeah they wouldn't
need to kill people they find ways to
legitimize the business yes and then
there's no issue but because your son's
an idiot yeah you need to murder the
competition yes instead of finding ways
to like lobby politicians to make your
business legal yes so in a weird way
nepotism
kills
institutions it does you is but i guess
it starves them of talent of talent now
the thing about mafia which is nice is
you get to like raise your employees
yeah the problem with bringing in talent
is they eventually they're sharks
that's right yeah that's right so that's
the tricky thing about it but but yeah
nepotism like i'm actually impressed
when a family can keep their [ __ ]
together
for centuries yeah like look at the
medicis in [ __ ] italy they last 100
years crazy or i don't know maybe it's a
little longer than that it's probably
longer but still it's like nothing it's
a blip
it to me the kennedys are broke yeah
yeah a lot of these are broken not all
of them but some of them the majority of
the kennedys
are a name yeah so they're no longer an
institution they couldn't keep it going
that [ __ ] joe kennedy they're not
relevant the bushes the bushes are not
relevant
bush's still got bread
they got bread but the kennedys probably
have just as much money they're just not
relevant anymore in the way that they
were right i mean they they were running
the the show for a little bit exactly
of you know like people have you read
about joe yes he orches he was like my
son's gonna be president and it wasn't
even jfk it was the other son yeah right
and then something happened to the other
side maybe he was killed in war some
[ __ ] like that but like they crafted
jfk's whole story about what happened
the whole thing family it was
orchestrated by this most of what you
read about a lot of these politicians is
a creation it's a narrative that's
invented and that's one of the things
that i find very interesting about about
those really wealthy families is that
they can push a narrative they have
institutional backing with media you
know with academia and the way that
these uh stories go out they're repeated
so many times they're not true yeah but
they're they become true but they become
true and people like them yeah so for me
like what we were going back to is like
are you gonna have the homeless guys in
the house it's like
no
unless they're like hung and respectful
yeah but for me it was like
it was always like i like the real
reality of what's going on even if it's
disturbing because that's where i could
make some kind of fun of it yes like if
i can confront it then that's where i
can make fun of it but i i it's not that
i'm some type of altruist or i'm out
there i'm not
giving people soup on the highway but i
do like sometimes i think the reality
like
the real story of the bush family's
success is much more interesting talk to
me than the story that's put out right
the real story
the real story is that a connecticut
preppy
bankers that descended from a preacher
who's you know if you trace the bush
family all the way back
their uh
their
samuel bush
it was either samuel or his father was a
minister and he ministered very wealthy
people in in connecticut and he became
friends with very wealthy people and the
family just started doing the bidding of
very very wealthy people and the
prescott bush became a senator and
george h.w bush uh became you know this
ambassador trump who's a cia agent and
all this stuff like this very
interesting thing and then you know they
were presented to us as kind of this
like texas free-spirited
you know they just they're watching
america connecticut these are
connecticut boring belt buckles and
everything they are you know kennebunk
eating uh lobster salad and it's just
they were able to invent this image of
like i'm a gunslinging free you know and
that's very interesting to me like being
able to do that on a massive scale when
everyone knows you are from connecticut
and doesn't care when everyone kind of
knows the truth and it doesn't matter
because you've laid the the fiction on
so thick because it's impressive it's
called um
mandela effect
yes mandela effect where it's like
berenstein bear berenstain bear strength
yeah whatever we just say ends up
becoming the reality that's choosing
this [ __ ] reality that's right so we
might as well choose the best version
that's here for 100 years the people in
the tents are having fun they love it
that's a good point they they've chosen
that ground that's right they're with
their friends they are with their
friends they have a great time here's
what i will say they are do you see them
crying i do seem to know each other
um
i don't see them crying i've heard
wailing i've heard wailing but whaling
might be happy yeah
yeah for sure
where can these people buy
my website the andrews.com
and then yeah we're gonna you can buy it
there will be like a two-week window
where you can buy it everybody who buys
it will get the special we're gonna send
you a link etcetera so you'll have it
what
are there's is there a live watch party
or something yeah every i wanna watch it
live with everybody 9 p.m eastern
standard time i kind of want to like
pay-per-view [ __ ] i stand up and i think
that's what i think we should do that i
think everybody should go watch it it's
like a fight everybody there's a time
which we do or like it exists in the
movie theater or exists online whatever
it is but i think we should do that in
the same way that movies have that like
i want sure people to watch this talk
about it all in the same time and
and yeah i don't know i just i don't
know i always feel future is [ __ ]
ownership man not not censorship and
it's just i don't know i i feel like i
feel like if
i feel like if it's raw if it's pure and
feel authentic and most importantly it's
just funny if people are like yo this is
funnier than the other things i'm seeing
then it wins simple it'll win
people will buy it y'all
more than cover your bet
uh as you always do
thank you for coming on thank you my
brother if you want to go now
do you have the food for the homeless
we're going to go around and give them
the food yeah i got it what'd you get
for them uh the greek yogurt uh well
it's
you got the greek yogurt for the
homeless yeah with the strawberries well
you know that's what i want
[Laughter]
and uh
go and pre-order the special now go
watch it live with him
um any closing thoughts nah you're done
you're great i [ __ ] think it's
awesome what you're doing and uh thank
you and i'm just i'm happy for your
success and it's it's always cool like
when friends will send me [ __ ] from you
oh yeah it's like it's like do you know
this guy no no one does that do they do
that your friends don't go hey do you
know this guy well no but everyone knows
we know all my friends know i know you
yeah
my friends are like real people i know i
have friends who have like kids and jobs
i know so it's like
by the way make a little more money go
get rid of them
you'll get rid of them i have friends at
kids and jobs too you ever hear them
talk it's exhausting i had my my friend
brought his wife over the other night
she came over in moccasins like an
animal
um you know
i have friends that are not in the
business i know giannis
the andrew schultz the andrew
schultz.com
[Music]